Alright, I'm slightly less overwhelmed now.
>> Great.
>> Let's fill the app. I'm guessing I do that
by, is it the big green button that says Add App?
>> You're so smart Andy.
>> Thanks, Sam.
>> Kay, so, what's the name of our app? What should we call it?
>> What are we trying to track?
>> Festivals?
>> Sounds good.
>> Check out Festival App. Okay?
>> That works. What's the main type
of data you need to track? That's festival
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Exactly. And you can see this little preview down there
of what it's actually going to look like once it creates it.
>> Yeah, okay, has me do the plurals. Doesn't figure
out the S by itself, but I guess that's acceptable.
>> Language is complicated.
>> Right, right. Create.
>> And so what this is going to do is
create a couple other things for us. It's created that
festival object, which we'll go a little bit into
what that is, to be able to store festival data.
>> Okay.
>> Then, it creates a permission set.
So if this were say a private thing that we
were trying to create, we could add some security around it.
>> Okay.
>> And it also adds a few other tabs into our application
so that we can do some other useful things besides just track festivals.
>> Okay.
>> So, why don't you click into, go into the app.
>> Okay. Alright.